hello everyone and welcome to another
very exciting game from round five of
the 2018 Norway championship it's again
between Magnus Carlsen you all know him
he's the world chess champion and he's
playing against Wesley so I Wesley
already won the rapid portion of the
Norway 2018 championship and now he has
the white pieces against Magnus Carlsen
which is definitely not a bad deal and
since you all enjoy the photo challenge
so much I decided to make it a bit more
difficult at this time so this photo
challenge will get you half a point for
one correct answer and another half 0.40
for the other correct answer but if you
know only you know the chess player that
will be completely sufficient so let's
check it out so who is the person on the
left so if you know that I'm pretty sure
you do but you know just checking
it's a photo from when he was younger
but you know I'm sure you you'll never
forget a smile such as this one and if
you know who the person on the right is
as well well then your then your
knowledge is beyond vast and I truly
congratulate you so that's for the photo
challenge I will not tell you who these
people are but you know the comments
section never lies most of the times and
we do have a couple of photos from from
this game let's let's check it out here
we have photo before the game started
here a nice hand check Wesley with the
white pieces and we do have another
photo from the middle of the game Carson
doesn't really enjoy his current
position and you know Wesley Wesley with
a nice poker face so let's let's check
out this game
Wesley opens with d4 in just a second
let me just fix that okay so he opens
with d4 we have d5 c4 and c6 Carson goes
for the Slav defense see capture son b5
the exchange variation C captures and de
Bishop to f4 Knight to f6 Knight to c3
Knight to c6 Knight to f3 and a6 rope to
c1 Bishop to f5 and III now rook to c8
we have
e to e six simply normal developing
moves
Wesley castles nice to d7 from b7 the
knight will you know have the knight has
a lot of a lot of ideas he can go to b6
to a four at the C for the knight can
control c4 nicely if white ever decides
to bring a knight over to c5 so
definitely a useful square for the
knight Knight we have Knight to a4
Bishop to e7 preparing the castle h3
crossing castles a3 now and Knight to a5
cousin would also enjoy bringing his
Knight over to c4 Knight does come to c5
and cross and also puts his knife to c4
before now now we have Knight captures
on c5 pawn d captures on c5 and now
Knight captures on a3 when Crossan
played this move he said it's only a
temporary pawn pawn sacrifice of course
but the variation he was expecting was
Queen to a4 and now of course the knight
is attacked and after the knight moves
Bishop captures on c4 pawn captures and
now of course you cannot capture with
the rook if you play rook captures then
you get b5 the queen is the tagged rook
is attacked and if you capture on
pasanda and rope capture some c4 as the
rockin c4 is undefended but after D
captures on c4 you can you can simply
play in 95 and now of course you will be
able to recapture after f6 Knight
captures you at E 5 and and black is
fine here so Carson didn't really see
any problems with this after Knight
captors on a3 but Wesley played night to
d4 first so now the bishop on f5 is
attacked you definitely don't wanna
allow this Knight captures this would
you know deprive cousin of the bishop
pair and also mess up his pawn structure
so Bishop to e4 f3 and now push it back
to g6 and Queen b3 now attacking the
knight Knight moves
we have Bishop captures on c4 d captures
on c4 and Queen captures on c4 so the
pawn is now returned Queen to e8 and
Bishop to g3 now Bishop to g3 as a very
nice move by Wesley the idea is if you
play
developing with something like luke fd1
then you run into e 5 e 5 comes with an
idea that after Bishop captures then
black has this Bishop captures on c5
idea pawn captures and now Queen
captures on e5 as the Bishop ear is
undefended and every four rook F to d8
and black is black is fine here even has
a nice passed pawn here so after Queen
to e8
rush up to g3 a very nice move e5 Knight
to b3 and Bishop to d8 now a Bishop to
d8 is a move that will that will prove
to be not not so great in the future but
it's it's very hard to see why here was
the place Queen to d5 he attacks at the
b7 pawn and now now you have a problem
if okay Carson played Queen to b5 he
defended the b7 pawn this way okay he
gives up the e5 pawn but let's say he
can capture the b4 pawn better move then
this would have been Bishop to g5 and
it's not only because first you attack
the three pawn and after the point is
defended and rook to c7 you can defend
this the reason why Bishop to g5 is is a
better defense than the MU Carson played
is because now after Queen to b5 the
problem is that your rooks are not
connected and it's very interesting how
Wesley immediately takes advantage of
this Bishop captures on e5 is played and
now Carson played Bishop to e7
the problem with Queen captures some
before immediately is that it run it
runs into Bishop to d6 now your rook is
under attack and you have to give up
this rook if you try to save it for
example rook to e8 then you run it to c4
c6 and it's all over your queen is under
attack and after B captures attacking
White Queen than simply Bishop captures
after pawn captures now you see the
problem your rooks are not connected and
your rook is undefended here white would
be up a whole rook so first cousin goes
Bishop to e7 now connecting rooks and
now where's the place Queen to d2 simply
defending his b4 pawn rook F to d8
attacking the Queen and now Bishop to d6
a very nice idea we have Bishop to f6
and II for now h6 we have 9th to d4
Bishop capture screen captures and rook
to e8 now rook F 2 e1 King to h7 and now
g4 expanding even further f6 and now f4
so Carson doesn't really have any active
plans and it's it's very hard to find a
useful move here
Queen to c6 we have f5 now Bishop to f7
and now H for preparing g5 in the near
future here cross someplace rook to e8
you will really enjoy pushing a 5 here
and what's the place rook to c2 we have
a 5 and now comes g5 capturing on G PI
g5 doesn't really do anything for black
and of course g6 would be a terrible if
Wesley could play this as it would win
the piece here so after Bishop to h5 we
have g6 check King to h8 and now comes
b5 a nice idea by Wesley Queen captures
on b5 and not rook to be to attacking
the Queen and here with Queen to d7
perhaps.perhaps Carlsen could still hold
on
but after Queen to c6 he allowed rook to
b6 this comes with an attack on the
Queen and after Queen to c8 we have
Queen to d5 and now you see that the b7
pawn is under attack and black is
completely tied down this bishop on d6
is a complete monster completely denying
black of any counter play and it's it's
pretty much useless to try and defend it
the b7 point if you play something like
rook to a7 then comes Queen to f7 and
now you're rockin a7 is is a huge
problem because c6 and you can never
capture the rook on a7 is undefended and
after black let's say makes a move a4
there really isn't any good move here
you can play c6 but even better is 'if
I've and after F captures Bishop
captures and I were threatening
checkmate after black stops this row to
g8 simply Bishop captures rook captures
and now rook to e8 check you win the
Queen in the game Queen captures
captures
and after Queen to f7 blackest black is
completely lost of course
so after Queen to d5 Carson decided I'm
not gonna even bother defending this he
played efore a4 we have rook capture
some b7 definitely the best idea and now
Rob the g8 Carson doesn't have time to
play a slow move for example a three if
he wants to continue pushing this pawn
because now you get rook captures and g7
simply as simple as that
after keen captures of course this will
result in checkmate so after work after
Sun b7 Rock to g8 was played c6 is
coming and it was in this position on
move 44 that world champion Magnus
Carlsen resigned the game and it's not
only that he resigned the game but this
is the first game actually the first
classical game that he lost in 2018 and
another thing it's the first game that
Wesley so has ever won against Magnus
Carlsen
in classical time format I believe it's
their 13th game or maybe limit but I'm
pretty sure it's 13th so yeah a huge win
for Wesley and he got a you know a nice
rating boost he won six points for this
for this victory and you know definitely
he reset the standings
so before we forget let's check out the
standings after round five so these are
the standings prior to rounds no sorry
these are the standings of round six
this is round six
sorry about that so Carson still in
first place but only leading with half a
point but he has three out of five out
of six yeah and what's the so is in
second place with three but out of five
so he will play one game more and then
we have our onion with three out of six
then Island with two and a half out of
five Nakamura with two and a half out of
five correct in with two and a half out
of five Fabiano with two and a half out
of five I'm mama dro would do and a half
out of six and Maxie mashaallah Grove
with two out of five so definitely
anything can happen and Wesley so after
winning this game so he is now I believe
the only player without
loss that has won at least one game
definitely an excellent position to be
in and we do have I believe this is ya
know we already saw that one but we do
have a very nice photo this is a photo
after the game there you know check
checking out probably some of the
variations cross some might have missed
but it was like I said in my previous
video it was what when Carson is doing
interviews before you know he always
said I I okay I was because I played
idiotic moves I mean idiot you know
it was like he said things like this
plenty of times but now after and while
he was making an interview he really
said that you know the only reason he
was this game is because I Wesley played
an excellent game and you know all the
credit goes to Wesley so definitely a
nice move by Carlson so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank all of our gear for a contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it and congratulations on
your great victories against your body
yeah as usual you can check to my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I'm really interested how
many of you will figure out this photo
challenge thank you all and I will see
you soon